[Inaudible] Oh, Steve jobs, autobiography.
Hello everyone.
Buddy.
So today we are going to talk about five tips to increasing your productivity.
Tip number one, leverage the power of habits to build productive routines.
I asked the guys for book recommendations on Twitter,
and one of the books I got was the power of habit.
Now I actually started listening to the audio book of it,
and I thought it was really interesting because it helped me understand how I
became more productive in the past year.
And now that I can pinpoint that it was because I was building a habit out of
the things I wanted to be productive on that I was able to make a routine and
start cranking out code videos, work stuff, you name it. Now,
essentially we want to do is for the next 21 days, do something every day.
This could be coding flossing or whatever you want that you think is productive.
And after 21 days, it will be so hard for you to stop.
That will become second nature to you. Tip number two, start multitasking,
the mundane stuff for things that doesn't require much concentration to do,
do something else that's more productive while you do that.
It would save you surprisingly a lot of time. For example,
when I clean my room or do something super boring, I usually do not like at all,
I would just, you know, whip out an audio book and just start listening to it.
And that way I can actually learn stuff while I do those mundane tasks.
Another example would be when I brush my teeth,
I would read emails or I would check my social media accounts.
And then little by little, I'm actually saving a lot of time in the long run
tip number three,
keep yourself busy and accountable with deadlines and stakeholders. Now,
one of the things I like to do is actually to fill out my calendar with lots of
focus, blocks and deadlines.
That way I barely have time to procrastinate the deadlines I set for myself,
or even better that I promised to other people will keep me accountable for
actually completing the projects.
That way I can't procrastinate because I just have a lot to finish.
And a lot of people are dependent on me to finish them.
Tip number four when taking a break, don't think about work. Just have fun.
This is important because I see a lot of people have faster productive time,
but they also have faster fun time. For example,
I see a lot of people studying while watching TV shows.
That's terrible because you end up not enjoying the show nor learning the things
or trying to learn. So when I give myself a break,
I make sure I don't think about anything else. I love TV shows.
So I turn off my phone and immerse myself and surprisingly,
you'll actually learn a lot more by doing that. Like for example,
I love to watch K-pop videos and actually learn a lot of cinematography by
dissecting these videos and just focusing on it.
But if I was coding while watching these K-pop videos,
I'd never appreciate them as much. Tip number five, exercise,
exercise, exercise. Now I'm a big fan of weightlifting.
So I might be biased here,
but I truly believe that exercising will make you sharper.
Exercising helps you relieve stress because it releases endorphins,
which are feel good hormones.
That way allows you to refresh your mind and be a lot more productive throughout
the day. It doesn't even need to be super-intense.
As long as you get your heart rate up and work on moving your body more,
you'll feel the benefits right away.
Exercise is a powerful habit and can be a good primer to, you know,
teaching you to how to build these productive habits.
So I highly recommend going to the gym or exercising regularly.
So in conclusion,
the most important point I want to get across is that if you really want to be
good at something, or you want to change an aspect of your life,
then make it a habit. Now you might say, Oh yeah,
it's not as easy as it sounds though. And you're absolutely right. You know,
building habits extremely hard and I find it hard myself,
but if you really care about the thing you want to achieve,
then you will put the effort into it.
And that's why I want to keep myself accountable for what I say.
And I want you guys to join me.
So basically choose something that you always wanted to do or something that you
want to get good at and together we'll make it a new habit. So for me,
this is running. I hate running every aspect of it.
I'm also extremely bad at it, but that's also why I want to work on it.
I want to have better cardio. And since I hate running the most,
I want to confront it. And if I can make running a habit,
then it gives me the confidence that in the future, I can make anything happen.
I also want to thank audible for sponsoring this video.
And I wanted to also recommend the audio book, the power of habit,
which I talked a lot about in this video.
And when you sign up for a free 30 day trial and audible today at
audible.com/joma, you can go and get that audio book.
That book really helped me become more productive and deconstruct the idea of
habits. And it's great. Cause now why run this summer? I can listen to it.
So I don't need to sit down and have a dedicated reading time. Uh,
they also have a huge library of other audio books you can listen to.
So if you want to get a free 30 day trial,
you can get it at audible.com/joma,
or you can text Joma to 500, 500.
So thank you Autobot again for allowing me to make this video.
And I hope you guys enjoyed it and don't forget to smash that like button and
subscribe.
[Inaudible].